ce matin vous avez eu la chance de faire
une visite privée de ce navire coriolis
2 c'est vraiment un laboratoire flottant
et c'est une chance inouïe pour - céline
parce que c'est le plus important navire
de recherche universitaire au pays
chance d'autant plus grande donc illyrie
gilles sous la responsabilité de
l'université du québec à rimouski et
c'est très précieux de la voir cette
semaine ici à rimouski
parce qu'on a fermé la jetée ouest du
quai de rimouski où normalement le
bateau et alors là il est amarré à
québec à 300 kilomètres jusqu'à temps
qu'on trouve une meilleure solution
pas très pratique pour les scientifiques
mais bref suis monté à bord aujourd'hui
avec des scientifiques qui m'ont montré
les instruments sophistiqués dont ils se
servent
on peut penser entre autres à des cures
sondeurs qui leur permettent de faire la
cartographie sous marine également
toutes les l'instrument pour faire des
prélèvements d'eau est également même
aller chercher des carottes de sédiments
au fond des mers c'est très précieux
pour les géologues ce bateau alors ce
que vous me dites c'est que c'est un
véritable trésor en fonte pour les
scientifiques vont assez cher d'ailleurs
tout à fait alors ça coûte à peu près au
baume ou l'autre vie mille dollars par
jour féline pour envoyer le coriolis ii
en mission un point tel que parfois pour
boucler le budget quand les subventions
de recherche se font plus rares on le
loue au secteur privé ont le même loué à
des pétrolières les six lutherie à payer
pour faire de la science et la science
le coriolis en a fait beaucoup
on a étudié l'érosion des berges du
saint-laurent l'impact des changements
climatiques
on a découvert des cratères des canyons
sous-marins élan aux parents mission
imaginer vers le gisement de old harry
dans le golfe saint-laurent et je vous
laisse le géologue marin lion mme
saint-onge le soin de vous décrire plus
en détail cette mission le but love
c'est vraiment d'avoir une étude
indépendante
une étude académique qui va réussir à
caractériser la région de robbery de
caractériser les sédiments de
caractériser les courants donc vraiment
de comprendre le système avant toute
exploitation
petra lire donc vraiment obtenir un
niveau de base au niveau de la
cartographie très détaillé il ya un gros
trou dans le golfe saint laurent c'est
carrément un trou donc on n'a pas ces
données de base là et pourtant c'est
important si on place des plateformes
pétrolières si on un jour on veut placer
des câbles sous marins par exemple donc
c'est aussi il ya un gros gros thon au
manque de connaissance sur la colonne
d'eau au manque de connaissance
également sur la scénographie donc sur
la physique très détaillée de la région
mais ce que c'est pas étonnant quand
même qu'on en sache si peu justement
cette partie du globe chanteur d'où
l'intérêt de cette mission céline qui va
nous apprendre vraiment une foule
d'informations c'est la première mission
océanographique a poussé vraiment à fond
l'étude des impacts environnementaux de
l'exploitation et même de l'exploration
les hydrocarbures dans le golfe du saint
laurent
alors on part pour deux semaines 14
scientifiques les chanceux ils s'en vont
au large les îles de la madeleine et des
côtes de terre neuve
d'ailleurs j'avais justement revenir
plus en détail sur cette mission du
cannabis dans le cadre de votre émission
les années lumière spéciale acfas ça
c'est dimanche en dimanche midi toute
l'émission consacrée donc aux travaux de
la phase et bien sûr à cette mission qui
s'en vient du coriolis deux donc c'est à
midi ce ici radio canada première on
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup chantal aura scellé